معنا من غلاف غزه مراسل الجزيره الياس
كرام الياس كنا نستمع معك في الساعه
الماضيه الى اصوات انفجارات عنيفه ما جديد
المشهد لديك
الان وهي مستمره كما تسمعين سهام وواضح
بان القصف المدفعي يشتد وهو متتال ولا
يتوقف منذ اكثر من ساعتين حقيقه وهو
يستهدف كل الاحياء الشماليه والشماليه
الشرقيه لمدينه غزه بما في ذلك الاحياء
الجنوبيه منها تحديدا في منطقه جحر الديك
التي كانت شهدت اشتباكات عنيفه ما بين
المقاومين الفلسطينيين وقوات الجيش
الاسرائيلي واضح من اعمده الدخان التي
تتصاعد في كل مكان في المناطق الشماليه
والشماليه الشرقيه لمدينه غزه على ان
المعارك هناك ضاريه وربما ان القوات
البريه تحتاج لكل هذا الاسناد المدفعي ايه
من غلاف غزه لتوجيه ضربات على اهداف
بعينها في داخل المدينه حيث يبدو ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يشتبك مع المقاومين
الفلسطينيين في اكثر من موقع وفي اكثر من
مكان واعاده عندما يشتد هذا القصف المدفعي
وتدخل على خطه ايضا الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه والمروحيات العسكريه التي تجب
اجواء المنطقه هذا يعني ان القوات البريه
على الارض تكون في مازق و انها ربما تكون
محاصره وانها تريد ربما هذا الغطاء الجوي
والمدفعي الكثيف من اجل الافلات من هذا
المازق او الوصول الى مناطقه بعينها ليس
فقط مدينه غزه هي التي تشهد هذا القصف
العنيف هنالك ايضا جحر الديك في المنطقه
الجنوبيه ل مدينه غزه هو محور ايضا مشتعل
في الساعات الاخيره ونستطيع ان نشاهد ايضا
اعم ده الدخان التي تتصاعد من هذهه
المنطقه على نحو كثيف حيث ان المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه لا تتوقف عن دك هذه المناطق
في الساعه الاخيره دعيني فقط اشير الى اي
تصريح مهم كانت اوردته القناه السابعه
الاسرائيليه قبل قليل عن رئيس الاركان
الاسبق في الجيش الاسرائيلي دان حالوتس
الذي كان ايضا رئيس لاركان الجيش
الاسرائيلي خلال العدوان على لبنان في عام
2006 القناه تنقل عن مصادر صحفيه وعن
مصادر خاصه بها كما يبدو في لقاء جمع
حالوتس مع عائلات الاسرى الاسرائيليين
المحتجزين في داخل قطاع غزه قوله لقد
خسرنا الحرب ضد حماس وانتصار سيكون فقط
بازاحه بنيامين نتنياهو عن السلطه وفي هذا
الحديث يقول حالوتس بان حربا او ان يتوقع
ان حربا اهليه ربما تقع في داخل اسرائيل
وقد تسفك فيها الدماء لان ميليشيات بن
كفير اصبحت مسلحه كما يقول دان حالوتس وهو
رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي الاسبق الذي
كان رئيسا للاركان خلال العدوان على لبنان
وهو واحد من اهم القيادات
العسكريه السابقه التي كانت
تقود الحراك الشعبي ضد بنيامين نتنياهو
وضد حكومته اليمينيه المتطرفه في الاشهر
الاخ فيما حاولت الحكومه الاسرائيليه
احداث الانقلاب القضائي في داخل اسرائيل
اذا هذا تصريح مهم لحالت ننقله عن القناه
السابعه الاسرائيليه وهي قناه يمينيه
وكذلك كانت القناه الرابعه ع الاسرائيليه
قد نقلته في الساعات الاخيره اذا سهام
الجيش الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن معارك ضاريه
ويتحدث عن انه يسعى الى توسيع نطاق عمليته
العسكريه في اكثر من موقع وفي اكثر من
مكان في داخل قطاع غزه هو يشير الى حيي
الدرج والتفاح في مدينه غزه وكذلك نحن نرى
الان على عبر الشاشه مع الزميل لبيب هذه
ال اعمده الدخان التي تتصاعد من الضواحي
الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه تحديدا في منطقه جحر
الديك والمغر هذه المناطق التي يعني تتعرض
منذ يومين الى تكثيف للغارات الجويه
وتكثيف للقصف المدفعي الشديد وكما تسمعين
سهام هذا القصف لا يتوقف الجيش الاسرائيلي
يقول في هذا السياق ويشدد في بياناته
العسكريه على ان سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي ما
زال يوفر اسنادا جويا للقوات البريه في
داخل قطاع غزه ولماذا يقول ذلك ويؤكد في
بياناته على هذا الامر تحديدا ويقول ذلك
لانه تعالت اصوات في داخل اسرائيل تقول
بان سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي ربما يقتصد في
الذخيره وان المدفعيه الاسرائيليه رب ربما
تقتصد في الذخيره في الايام الاخيره وانها
قللت في عمليات قصفها
والاغارة هي قويه الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول
بان سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي اغار على نحو
100 هدف فقط يوم امس في المنطقه الجنوبيه
لقطاع غزه في منطقه خانيونس التي تشهد
ايضا معارك واشتباكات كثيره ويؤكد في
بياناته العسكريه انه ما زال يحرز انجازات
كما يسميها على الارض في تفكيك البنى
التحتيه التابعه لحركه حماس الانفاق
الهجوميه الوصول الى مستودعات الاسلحه وما
الى ذلك والى منصات الصواريخ التي تطلق
منها الصواريخ سواء كان ذلك باتجاه غلاف
غزه او المناطق الشماليه او العمق ال
الاسرائيلي الجيش الاسرائيلي اشار في
تحديثه الصباحي الى انه اشتبك مع خليه من
المقاتلين الفلسطينيين في منطقه جباليا
هذه المنطقه التي كنا شهودا عليها في
الايام الماضيه وكانت تشهد معارك حقيقه
ضاريه الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول بانه اشتبك
مع خليه من الفلسطينيين خليه مسلحه مجموعه
مسلحه من المقاتلين الفلسطينيين و انه
تمكن من قتل عدد منهم بحسب بيانه عبر غاره
جويه استدعاها بعد ان علق ربما في قتال
شرس مع هذه المجموعه المسلحه اذا قتال لا
يتوقف في داخل القطاع وفي اكثر من مكان
وفي اكثر من محور وواضح بان الحسم العسكري
ليس واضحا وليس باديا يعني اليوم وكاننا
في اول ايام الحرب حقيقه بحجم هذا القصف
المدفعي الذي لا يتوقف نحن هنا في هذا
الموقع منذ اكثر من من ساعه وتقريبا
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه لم تتوقف ولو لدقيقه
واحده عن قصف هذه المواقع التي نشاهدها
سواء كان ذلك في منطقه جحر الديك والمغر
وكذلك في الضواحي الشماليه لمدينه غزه حيث
يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه يسعى الى
توسيع عملياته العسكريه فيها اذا تلاحظين
سهام كثافه ال النيران المدفعيه وهذه
الاصوات التي تاتي من منطقه غلاف غزه وتدك
هذه المناطق في داخل القطاع و كنا قد
شاهدنا ايضا حجم الدمار الهائل والكبير
الذي احدثته الاله العسكريه الاسرائيليه
في الايام والاسابيع الماضيه في عمر هذه
العمليه العسكريه هذه المناطق تحديدا
الواقعه الى الشرق من مدينه غزه كل ال
البيوت القريبه من السياج الامني تقريبا
نتحدث عن مئات المنازل وربما الاف الشقق
السكنيه سواء كان ذلك من المنطقه الجنوبيه
لقطاع غزه وحتى المناطق الشماليه لجبال
البلد وجباليا المخيم ونحن نشاهد حجم
الدمار الان عبر عدسه الكاميرا هذا الضمار
الكبير تتعمد الاله العسكريه الاسرائيليه
احداثه في تلك المناطق في اطار عمليه
تفريغ هذه المنطقه من السكان الفلسطينيين
وجعلها منطقه عازله منطقه خاليه من
الفلسطين وبالتالي هذا الدمار الكبير الذي
تحدثه في تلك المناطق هدفه تدمير هذه
المنازل على نحو تام على نحو لا يمكن
للفلسطينيين بعد انتهاء الحرب ان يكون
بمقدورهم ان يعودوا الى هذه المناطق ان
يعودوا الى منازلهم ان يعودوا الى مساكنهم
ليس فقط المنازل التي تستهدف هناك هنالك
ايضا منشات تجاريه ومنشات صناعيه ومنشات
مدنيه وبنى تحتيه يتم هدمها وتفجيرها ونحن
كنا قبل ايام شهودا على تفجيرات وتفخيخ
قام بها الجيش الاسرائيلي بمعنى ليس فقط
غارات جويه او قصف مدفعي في تلك المناطق
انما عمليه تفخيخ متعمده لبعض المنازل
ولبعض المنشات الصناعيه والتجاريه القريبه
من السياج الامني التي يتعمد الجيش
الاسرائيلي تدميرها في اطار خلق هذه
المنطقه العازله وهذه واحده من ال ال
العمليات التي يقوم بها الجيش الاسرائيلي
بالاضافه الى عملياته العسكريه بمع ان
هنالك قوات تعمل على في داخل قطاع غزه في
عمليه القتال ومواجهه المقاومه الفلسطينيه
في محاوله الوصول الى المستودعات و معاقل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وما الى ذلك وهنالك
قوات تابعه لوحدات الهندسه الاسرائيليه
ولقوات الجيش الاسرائيلي التي تعمل في
اطار هذه العمليه العسكريه على انشاء هذه
المنطقه العازله التي ستكون كما يبدو
منطقه يحضر الدخول اليها من جانب اي فل ين
وسوف تتضمن بالى جانب نصف هذه المنازل
وازالتها عن الوجود كما يبدو ترتيبات
امنيه وتحصينات عسكريه اسرائيليه هالله
سوف تقام كما يبدو في هذه المنطقه في اطار
العمليه العسكريه وهم يتحدثون عن عمليه
سوف تستمر لفتره طويله الياس كرام مراسل
الجزيره كنت معنا من غلاف غزه شكرا جزيلا
لك